What's your purpose?
What's your cause?
What's your belief?
Every single person,
every single organization
on theplanet
knows what they do,
100 percent.
Some know
how they do it,
but very, very fewpeople
or organizations
know why they do
what they do.
Well as a result,
the way we think,
the way we act,
the way we communicate
is from the outside in,
it's obvious.
We go from the clearest thing
tothe fuzziest thing.
But the inspired leaders
and the inspired
organizations --
regardless of theirsize,
regardless of their industry --
all think, act and
communicate
from the insideout.
And if you talk about
what you believe,
you will attract those
who believe what
youbelieve.
And it's those who
start with "why"
that have the ability
to inspire those
around them
or find others who
inspire them.